bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo de pourquoi sont-ils si
uniques aujourd'hui on s'attaque à l'un
des grands doyens de l'univers Marvel
j'ai nommé le Submariner Namor c'est un
personnage très particulier car
l'ancienneté de la mort est vraiment
quelque chose qui a façonné son histoire
à la base il était plus prévu pour être
un antagoniste mais avec l'arrivée de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et bien le
personnage va devenir plutôt une sorte
d'entité grise bon évidemment je le
répète à chaque émission vous commencez
à le savoir mais le concept de pourquoi
sont-ils si uniques restent quand même
de mettre en lumière les personnages de
Marvel tout en retraçant leur histoire
date par date mais voilà Namor ayant
plus de 83 ans ça en fait des comics et
des apparitions donc on ne va pas
pouvoir parler de tout nous allons nous
concentrer sur ce que j'estime le plus
pertinent et le plus important
concernant son histoire sur ce si vous
êtes prêts ne tardons pas plus longtemps
parlons du roi d'Atlantis
alias le fils vengeur des Atlantes
voyons ensemble pourquoi Namor et si
unique
dans Chrome
[Musique]
nous sommes le 31 août
1939 et cette date est très importante
car elle symbolise la sortie du tout
premier comics de la firme timely
publication qui deviendra dans le futur
la célèbre entreprise que vous
connaissez tous Marvel Comics bien
évidemment qui dit premier comics de la
firme Marvel dit forcément l'apparition
de leur premier super-héros et Namor en
fait partie dans la première production
nommée Marvel mystère et comics nous
suivons les aventures de plusieurs
personnages séparés en petites histoires
d'un côté nous retrouvons la Torche
Humaine de l'époque alias Jim Haymond
l'ange alias Thomas Aloe ou encore le
masque rider alias Jim garde etc etc
mais parmi tous ces nouveaux super-héros
se retrouvent incertain Submariner j'ai
nommé Namor dans sa toute première
épopée Namor qui vit dans les
profondeurs de l'océan tomber nez à nez
avec des plongeurs enquêtant sur la
disparition d'un navire se sentant
menacé le Submariner va rentrer en
confrontation avec les plongeurs qu'il
prend pour des robots et ni une ni deux
il va les assassiner en plus de détruire
le bateau de l'équipage le massacre
terminé va s'empresser de ramener les
cadavres de ces deux victimes dans un
royaume gisant dans les profondeurs de
l'océan il s'agit d'Atlantis là-bas le
summariner ira présenté ses trophées à
l'empereur et fera la terrible
découverte que les plongeurs étaient en
réalité des humains des hommes de la
surface derrière leur scaphandre
cependant à sa grande surprise Namor et
félicité pour ses actes la mère du
protagoniste la princesse fan explique à
son fils qu'elle est très fière de voir
que l'héritier du trône est déjà dans
une démarche de conquête par rapport aux
humains et qu'il a déjà commencé à
entamer la vengeance souhaitée du peuple
envers le monde de la surface Namor va
donc logiquement demander à sa mère
pourquoi les Atlantes en veulent aux
hommes de la terre et c'est alors que
ces dernières va nous compter une
première origine story 20 ans plus tôt
les hommes ont effectué d'innombrables
expériences d'armes ou autres arsenaux
dans l'océan et sans le savoir ces
derniers ont causé d'immenses dégâts qui
ont touché leur royaume d'atlantisme
causant la mort de plusieurs Atlantes la
jeune princesse fenne traite dévouée
envers son peuple et son royaume a donc
soif de vengeance et vu qu'elle est
celle qui ressemble le plus à une
humaine parmi son peuple et bien c'est
elle qui est envoyé à contrecoeur pour
découvrir ce qui se trame dans le monde
de la surface là-haut fêne en pleine
mission infiltration s'est fait
recueillir par les marins d'un navire
choqué de voir une femme seule dans les
eaux glacées fan est amené au capitaine
du bateau un certain Léonard McKenzie et
les deux protagonistes vont tout
doucement apprendre à se connaître sauf
qu'avec le fêne va finalement tomber
amoureuse du capitaine et de cette union
va finalement naître Namor un hybride
mi-atlante mi-humain malheureusement
cette histoire de vengeance reste quand
même toujours d'actualité et les
Atlantes toujours en colère vont
retenter de confronter les humains qui
vont anéantir leurs assaillants le
peuple Atlant a été décimé et il aura
fallu plus de 20 ans pour reconstruire
le royaume et être prêt à faire leur
grand retour Namor désigné comme un élu
de son peuple comme le Fils venger
alliant les forces du monde de la
surface et celles des océans de par sa
condition va donc prendre son rôle très
à coeur galvanisé par sa mère le Prince
va repartir pour engager la guerre avec
le monde de la surface et commencera les
hostilités avec une attaque sur un phare
gardé par de nombreux gardes qu'il
neutralisera
ce premier comics intégrant la mort est
très intéressante car il nous permet de
comprendre la vision des dessinateurs
concernant le personnage Namor est un
véritable surhumain aucun homme ne peut
le confronter et aucun atlante n'est son
égal il y a vraiment un côté élu tout
est fait pour nous démontrer l'unicité
de ce personnage et c'est unicité
possède une importance pour le récit car
déjà la condition hybride de la mort est
avant tout là pour permettre aux
personnages d'effectuer ses aventures
dans le monde de la surface néanmoins
bon il va falloir en parler Namor est un
héros qui va énormément servir la
propagande américaine concernant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale je vous le
rappelle mais nous sommes quand même en
1939 effectivement le fait que Namor est
un Atlant qui a peu côtoyé le monde de
la surface est un élément clé qui va
permettre aux dessinateur de nous
proposer une image unique de l'Amérique
au travers des yeux d'un personnage
normalement neutre et qui ne connaît
rien aux hommes et soit dit en passant
c'est la première fois que New York
apparaît dans un comics Marvel donc il
fallait trouver un moyen cohérent de
montrer la ville au lecteurs et du coup
alors que Namor a tout pour devenir un
véritable antagoniste une véritable
menace pour l'humanité est en désigné
comme le Fils vengeur des Atlantes
envers les hommes avec la guerre le
personnage va plutôt se dévoiler comme
une entité grise c'est à dire que cette
histoire de vengeance restera quand même
toujours d'actualité mais finira plutôt
au second plan pour que Namor a inspire
les citoyens américains en combattant
les forces du Troisième Reich le 13
octobre 1939 sortira le second comics de
la saga Marvel mystery comics Namor
toujours en quête de vengeance va
finalement atterrir dans la ville de New
York ne connaissant rien à la vie
humaine le personnage va découvrir avec
ses yeux d'atlantes ce qui composent la
vie de la surface désireux d'entamer la
guerre avec les humains le Prince va
effectuer par-ci par là quelques phrases
que qui vont alerter la police locale à
terme n’amor va tent kidnapper une jeune
femme pour en faire son otage sauf que
la police interviendra et durant la
confrontation Namor va noyer un des
policiers interloqués par cette nouvelle
menace la police va mettre au point un
stratagème pour attraper le Submariner
une jeune policière du nom de Betty DIN
sera désigné pour faire la pas en
simulant une fausse noyade bien
évidemment Namor n’étant pas
foncièrement mauvais sera attiré par la
ruse des policiers et va aller sauver la
jeune femme néanmoins se rendant compte
sur le fait de la supercherie Namor va
emmener Betty beaucoup plus loin dans la
mer et c'est alors que sous ses yeux un
sous-marin allemand est en train
d'attaquer un cargo britannique sans
hésitation Namor va sauver le cargo et
les hommes à bord puis détruira le
sous-marin attaquant Betty très surprise
des capacités de la mort et de ce qu'il
est capable de faire va tenter de le
convaincre de rejoindre les forces
alliées cette dernière va faire
comprendre à Namor que les Américains ne
sont pas de mauvaises personnes et que
justement Namor devrait s'allier à eux
car le Troisième Reich gagne en
puissance et ces derniers sont une
menace pour le monde entier ce qui veut
dire requête Atlantis en fait partie les
Américains et la mort ont donc un ennemi
commun et tout cela va faire réfléchir
le jeune prince et c'est là que
l'histoire de la mort devient très
particulière en fait avec l'apparition
de la guerre les comics vont petit à
petit installer une certaine propagande
pour toucher les jeunes lecteurs là où
le premier comics instaure quand même
des éléments clés pour la mort ainsi
qu'une direction pour le développement
de son personnage la Seconde Guerre
mondiale va complètement chambouler tout
ça et à terme de 1939 aux années 50
Namor va devenir un héros de propagande
comme ces autres compères de l'époque
par exemple il va continuer ses
aventures dans la saga Marvel mystery
comics qui contient quand même plus de
92 histoires il aura également une série
dédiée à partir de 1941 nommé the
summariner comics il apparaîtra
également aux côtés de la torche humaine
ou encore Captain America dans la série
young mène dans les années 50 mais voilà
avec la guerre Namor sera peu développée
ils jonglera entre vengeance des
Atlantes combat contre les forces
allemandes de nouveau sa vengeance puis
encore des affrontements contre le
Troisième Reich et finalement arrivé
dans les années 50 avec la fin de la
guerre et l'arrivée de la guerre froide
Namor se mettra à affronter les
communistes jusqu'à au final tomber
petit à petit dans l'oubli à l'époque
vers la moitié des années 50 l'industrie
des comics va plutôt mal il y a
clairement un déclin concernant la
popularité des comics liés au
super-héros et pour cause étant devenu
un outil de propagande et bien la fin de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale va
complètement desservir la vente de
comics donc si Namor finit petit à petit
par tomber dans l'oubli et bien c'est
parce que timili eux-mêmes commencent à
sombrer mais vous vous en doutez
l'histoire va renaître et pas de
n'importe quelle manière puisque le 8
août 1961 la saga fantastique fort va
émerger la nouvelle série principale
dont la continuité s'étend jusqu'à
aujourd'hui timely publications René de
ses cendres et devient à partir de ce
moment-là l'entreprise que vous
connaissez tous j'ai nommé Marvel Comics
ce qui va nous intéresser à partir de
maintenant c'est le comics numéro 4 des
fantastiques forts sorti le 8 février
1962 car c'est le grand retour de la
mort là-bas nous suivons bien évidemment
les aventures des Quatre Fantastiques
comme à leur habitude la chose la torche
sont en train de se chamailler et cette
fois-ci Johnny saoulait va finalement
vouloir s'isoler pour être tranquille
installé dans un hôtel le protagoniste
va lire à un comics retraçant les folles
épopées de Namor durant la guerre et
Johnny va même se poser la question de
savoir ce est devenu car après tout
Namor d'après les légendes bah il est
censé être immortel et surpuissant donc
il doit bien toujours exister quelque
part c'est alors que coup de théâtre
dans ce même hôtel un vieil homme qui
semble avoir perdu la mémoire se mettent
à se battre avec d'autres personnes la
torche va donc intervenir et va
finalement se rendre compte que
l'amnésique est en fait le légendaire se
marineur Namor le prince d'Atlantis
interloqué de retrouver le héros de ses
comics Johnny va prendre une amorce sous
son aile et va tenter de trouver un
moyen de lui redonner la mémoire une
idée va alors submerger dans l'esprit de
la torche si l'amnésique est bel et bien
à mort alors de par sa condition
d'Atlante la mère et l'océan devrait
pouvoir lui venir en aide Johnny va
alors plonger le Submariner dans l'eau
et ni une ni deux Namor va retrouver ses
pleines capacités et son esprit son
premier réflexe a bien évidemment de
retourner à Atlantis malheureusement le
temps a passé Namor qui était devenue le
roi et le dirigeant du royaume a été
absent pendant de longues années et
Atlantis n'est désormais plus qu'une
ruine fantôme il n'y a plus aucun
natelante là-bas le prince enragé va
donc suspecter les hommes d'avoir causé
cette tragédie de part les histoires
passées du royaume et cela va raviver ce
profond désir de vengeance qui l'animait
depuis le départ une fois revenu vers
Johnny Namor annonce la couleur il est
temps pour lui de détruire l'humanité
affoler la torche va appeler les Quatre
Fantastiques en urgence car Namor est
déjà en route pour saccager New York un
combat va alors éclater entre le groupe
et le Submariner et éléments
intéressants Namor va tomber sous le
charme de Suzanne Storm la femme
invisible et épouse de Ried Richard mais
finalement à terme n'amorcera repoussé
grâce aux actions Johnny le prince
désormais roi avertit l'équipe qu'il
reviendra et que cette histoire est très
loin d'être terminée ce retour est
intéressant car il annonce clairement la
renaissance du personnage dans une
nouvelle ère moderne de la saga Marvel
tout ce qui composait mort à l'époque a
été retranscrit pour respecter le
personnage et nous confirmer que ok
Namor c'était ça avant on ne l'oublie
pas on respecte son histoire mais il est
désormais temps de passer à autre chose
la mise en abyme de Johnny et lisant un
comics centré sur la mort et pleine de
sens car cela retranscrit l'utilité du
personnage dans les années 40 Namor
était un héros de propagande une légende
qui influençait les lecteurs de comics
d'ailleurs le fait que ce soit Johnny
qui permet à la mort de retrouver la
mémoire n'est pas anodin car cela fait
écho à la liaison que Namor avait à
l'époque avec l'ancienne Torche Humaine
Jim Hammond et tout comme sa relation
avec Betty DIN ici Susan Storm reprend
un peu ce rôle de femme qui ne
connaissent pas le seul mariner
indifférent et bien évidemment la perte
de mémoire le fait que la mort soit
devenue une sorte de SDF tout ça je
pense que vous l'avez compris mais c'est
lié au fait que le héros n'était devenu
qu'un souvenir avec le déclin de
l'industrie des comics néanmoins tout ça
c'est désormais révolu Namor et de
retour sur la scène le Submariner
réapparaîtra ensuite dès le comics
numéro 6 des 4 Fantastiques sortis le 12
juin 1962 après l'intégration du docteur
dome dans le comics 5 nous ferons face
ici à une alliance des deux personnages
pour confronter l'équipe des Quatre
Fantastiques pour faire bref Doom va
manipuler la mort en lui rappelant la
souffrance que le peuple atlante a subi
à cause des humains ce qui va pousser le
Submariner de nouveau en colère à
s'allier au docteur par le biais de la
technologie de Doom le Baxter Building
le QG des Quatre Fantastiques sera
emmené dans l'espace avec l'équipe de
super-héros à l'intérieur finalement
grâce à la parole de su plateforme dont
Namor semble être plutôt sensible et se
rendant compte que Doom n'en a rien à
faire de son coéquipier qui risque de
mourir également avec les Quatre
Fantastiques Namor va se retourner
contre le docteur qui finira perdu dans
l'espace et le Baxter Building sera
finalement ramené sur terre 3 comics
plus tard nous retrouvons cette fois-ci
les Quatre Fantastiques au bord de la
faillite nos super-héros sont dans une
véritable situation de crise financière
à tel point qu'ils sont au bord de la
séparation et sont obligés de vendre les
inventions de ridre Richards pour
survivre c'est alors que Namor
surveillant les actions de ses ennemis
depuis son lointain royaume va estimer
que c'est le bon moment pour frapper de
manière anonyme le Submariner va
investir dans un studio de cinéma grâce
aux nombreux trésors qui jonchent le
fond des océans et faire la proposition
aux Quatre Fantastiques de tourner un
biopic sur leur vie en échange d'un très
gros paquet d'argent qui rembourserait
totalement les dettes du groupe bien
évidemment de cette mise en scène était
un piège Namor va duper les Quatre
Fantastiques sur le tournage du film
pour pouvoir s'isoler avec sous Storm se
rendant compte de la supercherie ben
Johnny et rides voudront se venger mais
Suzanne sensible à la mort réussira à
calmer la situation le roi d'Atlantis
décidera finalement grâce à Suzanne de
respecter le contrat et le Submariner
sauvera financièrement les Quatre
Fantastiques nous retrouverons également
Namor le 10 janvier 1963 ainsi que
Johnny Storm dans une courte histoire de
la série strange certainement en hommage
à la rivalité de la première Torche
Humaine Jim hemmen face à la mort ici
nous avons Johnny qui souhaite faire ses
preuves en solo en provoquant à versus
avec le roi d'Atlantis sans oublier le
comics 14 des 4 Fantastiques unamor sera
contrôlé par le puppetmaster soit le
marionnettiste un ennemi récurrent du
groupe de super-héros qui souhaitent
cette fois-ci se servir du Submariner
pour asservir les Quatre Fantastiques à
distance heureusement Suzanne dont la
relation avec Namor commence à devenir
spécial réussira à comprendre la
situation en étant témoin que Namor
n'est plus du tout lui-même néanmoins ce
qui va nous intéresser désormais c'est
la sortie du premier comics fantastique
fort annuel sortie le 2 juillet 1963 car
c'est le premier événement de Namor et
du peuple Atlant dans la nouvelle saga
Marvel apportée par la série des Quatre
Fantastiques que l'on qualifierait d'âge
d'argent là-bas nous retrouvons un amor
qui retourne complètement aux sources de
son personnage effectivement le Prince
des Mers a enfin retrouvé le peuple
Atlant qu'il avait perdu durant le temps
de son amnésie et de son absence le
Submariner va se faire couronner et
acclamer par ses congénères nous
retrouvons d'ailleurs Lady Dorma qui
était la promise de la mort durant l'âge
d'or des comics et c'est également
l'intégration de nouveaux personnages
comme le général Krang qui était un peu
le leader de substitution pendant que
Namor n'était pas là galvanisé par les
retrouvailles et n'oublions pas la
souffrance du peuple Atlant dont la
dispersion a été causée par les humains
n'a mort après son ascension va
directement entamer les hostilités pour
déclarer la guerre au monde de la
surface en premier lieu grâce à l'aide
de créatures maritimes il va piéger les
Quatre Fantastiques c'est Nemesis
actuellement en croisière pour prévenir
l'humanité de l'arrivée prochaine des
Atlantes et accessoirement avoir le
champ libre sans que les héros
n'intervienne pour empêcher l'invasion
cependant grâce à l'intervention de Ried
Richards l'équipe des fantastiques vont
finalement se libérer et iront prévenir
le gouvernement américain de la menace
grondante que symbolise les Atlantes une
réunion d'urgence sera alors organisée
pour comprendre la race des Atlantes et
trouver une solution dans le but de les
contrer pour la première fois dans
l'histoire des comics grâce au docteur
Jay de bollywalton nous allons avoir
enfin une origine Story pour le peuple
Atlant l'homme des maires comme il est
appelé scientifiquement par l'humanité
serait apparemment une branche de
l'évolution de l'homme qui se serait
développée dans les océans l'homo
mermanus tout comme l'humanité ces
derniers ont évolué mais dans leur cas
dans des conditions aquatiques ils ont
connu l'âge de pierre si on peut appeler
ça comme ça ils ont connu la chasse les
guerres le développement de la
technologie jusqu'à devenir aussi
évoluer que l'homme de la surface mais
sur le plan marin et pour conclure le
docteur nous fera part également de
l'histoire unique de la mort comme quoi
il est le premier hybride entre la race
des hommes et des Atlantes ainsi que le
premier mutant de par sa capacité de
voler grâce à ces petites ailes
désignées comme le Fils vengeur de son
peuple qui doit guider les Atlantes vers
la vengeance et la justice face aux
actions passées de l'humanité néanmoins
c'est intrigant qu'un en sache autant
sur Atlantis et son histoire et bien
toute cette mise en scène était en fait
une usurpation de Namor qui était
déguisé en scientifiques le protagoniste
voulait savoir le plan des hommes
concernant la future guerre avec les
Atlantes et étant témoin que riedrich
Charles souhaite la confrontation avec
la mort enlèvera son déguisement pour
faire appel à ses troupes New York sera
envahi et prix d'assaut ni l'armée
américaine ni les Quatre Fantastiques
réussiront à stopper les Atlantes et
pire que ça le Pentagone sera même
obligé de laisser l'invasion se produire
car ils ne peuvent pas frapper New York
dont la population humaine s'élève à
plus de 9 millions d'habitants Namor a
agi stratégiquement avec surprise et
réflexion l'humanité a été prise de
cours néanmoins c'est à ce moment qu'une
idée va émerger dans la tête du brillant
réderie Richards les Atlantes sont des
hommes de l'océan ce qui signifie que
ces derniers ne peuvent respirer l'air
de la surface ils utilisent des casques
avec de l'eau à l'intérieur pour
contrebalancer rides va donc mettre au
point une machine permettant
l'évaporation de l'eau et les guerriers
Atlantes à l'exception de Namor vont
tous commencer à suffoquer les
obligeants à retourner dans la mer
désormais seul à pouvoir continuer la
guerre le roi d'Atlantis rentrera dans
une rage folle et va directement
comprendre que ride et derrière tout ça
après avoir neutralisé Richards la
torche et la chose n'amorent kidnappera
une nouvelle fois Suzanne en otage bien
évidemment les fantastiques n'en
resteront pas là et l'affrontement va
continuer sauf que malheureusement tout
va dégénérer Dorma qui est normalement
promise à la mort va se rendre compte
que le Submariner est en réalité
amoureux de Suzanne Storm et dans sa
colère va tenter de noyer l'héroïne la
mort et les fantastiques
vont alors être témoins du corps inanimé
de Suzanne au milieu de l'océan ni une
ni de l'affrontement entre les
protagonistes va se stopper pour sauver
la femme invisible Suzanne au bord de la
mort sera finalement sauvé à temps grâce
à Namor qu'il a amené à l'hôpital
quelques minutes avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard à la sortie du bâtiment Namor
sera hué par les humains et une fois de
retour à Atlantis il retrouvera un
royaume complètement vide les Atlantes
l'ont abandonné horrifié que le jeune
roi est préféré sauver une humaine que
de soutenir son peuple c'est une
véritable trahison
ce comics est intéressant car nous avons
enfin un peu de background ne concernant
l'histoire des Atlantes mais pas
seulement déjà on se rend compte
clairement que Namor a une utilité
scénaristique pour les Quatre
Fantastiques effectivement il ne faut
pas oublier que bien que nous nous
concentrions sur Namor durant cette
vidéo et bien concernant les comics pour
le moment nous restons quand même avant
tout dans la saga fantastique fort comme
je vous l'expliquais dans la vidéo
dédiée à Dr Doom Victor avait été conçu
pour être le nouvel ennemi
ultime des Quatre Fantastiques néanmoins
de par son origin story son leadership
ou encore son intelligence on s'est
rendu compte que Victor était quand même
beaucoup plus un Némésis pour
redrichards le chef des Quatre
Fantastiques et bien ici Namor sert
justement à la même chose mais par
rapport à Susan Storm Namor février sous
Storm la femme invisible à chaque
apparition de Namor de par ses
sentiments Suzanne la femme invisible
sera toujours l'élément clé de
l'histoire permettant de résoudre la
situation et ce même dans les pires
moments comme dans fantastic for annuel
cependant à contrario c'est quelque
chose qui va desservir la mort de
l'autre côté et nous démontre que le
personnage n'est pas encore prêt à
devenir le souverain affirmé qu'Atlantis
a besoin la mort n'est jamais juste il
n'est jamais dans la demi-mesure sa
condition d'hybride le déchire un coup
il veut l'anéantissement de l'humanité
mais de l'autre côté il n'arrête pas de
la sauver au travers de Suzanne dont il
veut en faire sa reine donc
obligatoirement cela déplaît aux
Atlantes et à force d'indécision à force
de tout vouloir il finit par se
retrouver avec rien du tout la mort par
la suite aura toujours ce rôle de faire
rayonner entre guillemets les héros
puisque nous le reverrons dans le comics
Avengers numéro 3 sorti le 5 novembre 63
où il tentera de récupérer Hulk qui est
actuellement pourchasser par les autres
Avengers car il est un danger pour la
population mais au final une fois que
Hulk sera redevenu Banner la raison lui
reviendra il abandonnera son allié et
pareil pour le comics Avengers 4 ou 7
fois ci la mort va décongeler par une
advertance Steve Rogers qui sommeille
dans la glace depuis son crash en 1945
par facilité scénaristique Namor et
Captain America ne se reconnaîtront pas
à ce moment-là avec la justification de
la perte de mémoire et les problèmes
liés aux souvenirs et au final Namor
servira d'ennemis principal pour unir
les Avengers et leur nouveau membre
Captain America mais toutes les bonnes
choses ont une fin et il faut désormais
que Namor avance et c'est ce qu'il va se
passer dans le comics 27 des Quatre
Fantastiques par chance pour Namor tous
les Atlantes n'ont pas déserté une
poignée de soldats extrêmement fidèle au
Submariner reviendront pour servir leur
roi cependant la mort est toujours
aveuglé étant désormais accompagné par
d'autres Atlantes il va ordonner une
fois de plus le kidnapping de Suzanne
Storm pour en faire sa femme et sa reine
Namor ne semble toujours pas réalisée la
situation et même ces sujets les plus
fidèles sont prêtes à le déserter
définitivement de l'autre côté ride
était sur le point de demander sous en
mariage et sachant que son aimer est
encore une fois enlevé par la mort va
rentrer dans une rage folle après
quelques péripéties et un terrible
affrontement entre les Quatre
Fantastiques et Namor accompagné de sa
poignée de soldats Suzanne va enfin
mettre un terme au combat oui suzanne a
de la sympathie pour la mort oui elle a
de l'affection pour lui mais ce n’est en
aucun cas de l'amour le cœur de la Femme
Invisible appartient à Monsieur
fantastique riedrich Charles Namor
restera seul et désorienté mais aura
enfin compris qu'il de passer à la suite
maintenant des faits de ses sentiments à
sens unique l'ascension de la mort va
enfin pouvoir s'effectuer Lady Dorma la
promise de la mort va aller à la
rencontre des Quatre Fantastiques pour
leur implorer de l'aide en réalité à
cause de la précédente trahison de Namor
dans fantastique fort annual numéro 1 où
il voulait faire de Suzanne son épouse
et bien Dorma pour se venger est allé à
la rencontre d'atoma un barbare atlante
pour que ce dernier ainsi que ses
troupes viennent envahir Atlantis Namor
qui a depuis retrouvé les Atlantes va
bien évidemment essayer par tous les
moyens de défendre son peuple sauf que
Atoma n'est pas quelqu'un de loyal et
honnête le Submariner va se retrouver
dans un duel l'opposant à son
envahisseur mais ce dernier a prévu de
nombreux pièges pour faire tomber le roi
d'Atlantis comprenant l'ampleur de la
situation car à Thomas est bien plus
cruel que Namor qui a démontré qu'il
était un souverain quand même
mesurer que le barbare les Quatre
Fantastiques accompagnés de Dorma vont
dans le plus grand des secrets anéantir
les pièges organisés par atuma et ses
troupes ce qui permettra à Namor de se
battre en pure incontin bien évidemment
de par sa condition de mutant et
d'hybride n'amor viendra facilement à
bout d'atoutsma éprouvera à tous les
Atlantes présents sa supériorité ce que
j'aime bien avec ce comics c'est que bon
déjà Namor passe enfin à autre chose il
est désormais enfin prêt à devenir le
souverain qu'Atlantis a besoin mais
surtout comme on disait un peu plus tôt
Namor est un personnage qui fait briller
les héros et notamment les Quatre
Fantastiques et ici le comics nous
propose l'inverse nous sommes dans une
histoire des Quatre Fantastiques mais
ces derniers sont plus dans un rôle de
soutien par rapport à la mort ils vont
l'aider et le soutenir dans l'ombre
c'est comme si dans le symbole les
Quatre Fantastiques rendaient l'appareil
à leur ennemi Namor les affaiblies
pendant un long moment et maintenant
c'est à eux de faire briller la mort et
de le mettre au devant de la scène le
protagoniste réapparaîtra dans le comics
X-Men numéro 6 car on le rappelle quand
même mais de par sa condition bah Namor
est un mutant nous le reverrons
également dans Daredevil 7 ou le
Submariner voudra confronter l'humanité
juridiquement pour toute la pollution
qu'ils amènent dans les océans mais le
prochain gros morceau de l'histoire de
la mort ce sera la saga de comics tail
toastonish à partir du numéro 70 suite à
ces péripéties sur la terre avec
Daredevil Krang le général Atlant qui
était présent dans le comics fantastique
fort annuel revient pour faire un coup
d'état durant l'absence du roi
d'Atlantis pour prendre le pouvoir
décider à assumer son rôle n'a mort ira
directement à la confrontation
malheureusement il finira enfermer par
le biais de Dorma le summariner va
finalement réussir à s'enfuir et avec un
projet en tête retrouvez le trident de
Neptune une arme
disparu et très symbolique pour les
Atlantes à terme la mort finira par
passer plusieurs épreuves pour trouver
la fameuse arme il enchaînera la quête
des indices sauf qu'au moment où il
approchera du but Lady dormas sera
gravement blessé sans hésiter le
summariner abandonnera sa quête pour
sauver sa promise et c'est alors que
témoin du profond courage et du cœur
puissant que possède la mort Neptune
lui-même interviendra pour octroyer sa
bénédiction aux fils vengeur et Namor
réussira par la suite grâce à la
nouvelle puissance que lui octroie
l'arme à défaire krangue et redevenir le
souverain légitime d'Atlantis par la
suite la saga astonish développera de
nombreux comics où nous pourrons suivre
la vie de Namor Krang sera de retour dès
le comics suivants il kidnappera Dorma
et nous ferons face à une course
poursuite ou la mort tentera de la
sauver incluant au passage d'autres
personnages comme Iron Man dans la saga
Tales of suspens nous aurons également
le retour datuma ou encore Bira le
cousin de Namor mais le plus intéressant
sera quand même la fin de l'épopée en
fait nous commençons à arriver à un
moment un peu particulier de l'histoire
de Namor contrairement aux autres
personnages de comics n’a mort fait
partie des toutes premières entités de
l'univers Marvel là où les Quatre
Fantastiques n'ont que 6 ans d'existence
et bien amor a déjà presque 30 ans il y
en a eu des comics le concernant des
histoires des dessinateurs qui se sont
occupés de lui il a traversé le temps il
a connu l'époque timely publications
puis leur renouveau en Marvel Comics
bref Namor a du vécu quoi sauf que c'est
là qu'une difficulté se dessine à
l'époque Namor servait à mon tour de
personnages de propagande durant la
guerre sauf que quand tamly publications
à tout balayé pour tout recommencer et
c'est relever la mort était toujours là
et c'est ça le point important Namor
manque de profondeur son histoire a
connu d'innombrables facilités
scénaristique ou le pansement pour
coller à l'air moderne de la saga Marvel
mais du coup de l'autre côté on perd en
cohérence et en justification Namor a
décongelé Steve Rogers mais ne le
reconnaît pas alors que pourtant ils ont
combattu ensemble pendant la guerre il
ne reconnaît pas Hulk dans la saga Tales
toastonish alors qu'ils se sont côtoyés
dans les premiers comics Avengers et on
mettra ça à chaque fois sur le dos de la
pseudo amnésie entre l'âge d'or soit
l'époque de la guerre et l'âge d'argent
l'arrivée de la saga des Quatre
Fantastiques du coup pour pallier à ça
deux stratégies seront opté pour le
développement du personnage de Namor
d'un côté les dessinateurs de Marvel
Comics vont juger que le meilleur moyen
de faire briller le Submariner avec son
manque de profondeur c'est de le faire
participer dans un groupe ou du moins
qu'il soit en partenariat avec d'autres
personnages et de l'autre côté des
comics sur la période de l'âge d'or de
Marvel seront développés des comics qui
étoffront le passé ou qui seront dans
une réécriture beaucoup plus profonde de
cette période suite à l'épopée Tales
toastonish le dernier comics de la saga
ainsi que le comics Iron Man n The
Submariner se concentreront sur la
justification de l'amnésie du personnage
alors que Namor vit de nombreuses
péripéties où il va se retrouver seul
dans une caverne le roi d'Atlantis va
commencer à faire de drôles de rêves et
ressent une drôle de sensation comme une
sorte d'appel à force de suivre ses sens
la mort atterrira finalement en
Antarctique et plus précisément dans une
sombre caverne là-bas un drôle de
personnage va faire son apparition et va
narguer Namor en lui rappelant des
souvenirs enfouis que le Submariner
avait oublié finalement l'antagoniste va
s'identifier et nous expliquer son
histoire de son vrai nom Paul destine il
était un mentaliste avec certaines
capacités télépathiques lui permettant
de faire son beurre dans des carnavals
mais un jour sa télépathie va le guider
à prendre son son vol pour se diriger
vers l'Antarctique le personnage va donc
monter à bord du bateau du capitaine
Léonard McKenzie et une fois arrivé
l'autoproclamé Destiny va faire la
découverte d'une relique ancienne un
casque de puissance qui va grandement
améliorer ses pouvoirs néanmoins étant
actuellement trop faible dans les années
1920 Destiny va entrer en hibernation et
ce jusqu'en 1958 ou à son réveil il
essaiera ses nouveaux pouvoirs Paul va
engendrer d'innombrables tremblements de
terre et bien évidemment et tant en
Antarctique Atlantis sera touché ce qui
va conduire n’a mort envoyé par
l'empereur à enquêter sur le phénomène
finalement le Submariner va rencontrer
ce fameux Destiny mais sera
malheureusement vaincu Destiny va donc
envoyer la mort à New York et le rendre
amnésique et causer la destruction
d'Atlantis se provoquant au passage la
mort de l'empereur et de la princesse
peine la mère de Namor néanmoins ne se
sentant pas encore assez puissant
Destiny va retourner en hibernation
encore une fois et ce jusqu'à l'heure
actuelle ayant maintenant pleinement
conscience de ces souvenirs disparus et
désireux devant Jean par rapport à la
mort de sa mère Namor partent à la
recherche de Destiny qui a profité des
visions du Submariner pour s'enfuir nous
le retrouverons six comics plus tard ou
ce dernier va tenter de devenir
président des États-Unis pour déclencher
le chaos partout sur terre de par sa
campagne présidentielle na mort va
retrouver non sans mal son ennemi et un
affrontement va s'engendrer grâce à son
casque de puissance Destiny va prendre
le dessus sur la mort et le jeter du
haut d'un immeuble sauf que dans un
excès de confiance et de folie des
grandeurs Destiny va jeter son casque de
puissance assurant qu'il est désormais
tellement puissant qu'il n'en a plus
besoin et se prépare à l'éviter de
lui-même depuis le haut de l'immeuble
en sautant du toit Paul destine va
finalement juste s'écraser au sol et
provoquer sa propre mort la saga se
mariner donnera beaucoup de liberté à la
mort lui permettant de se développer et
raccrocher certains événements du passé
nous aurons l'occasion de retrouver
Betty Dean le premier amour de la mort
maintenant très âgée ou encore taureau
l'un des premiers héros de l'époque de
l'âge d'or qui a côtoyé la mort des
histoires liées à d'autres personnages
que ce soit des héros comme les Avengers
ou des antagonistes comme le docteur
Doom ou modoch bref la saga Submariner
contrat plus de 72 histoires et se
terminera le 18 juin
1974 entre temps Namor apparaîtra
toujours de temps en temps pour
agrémenter certaines histoires comme
dans fantastique fort 104 il intégrera
également l'équipe des Defenders dès
1972 aux côtés notamment de Dr Strange
ou encore Hulk enfin il apparaîtra aussi
dans la saga invaders
sans les histoires du passé en compagnie
de Captain America Bucky ou encore la
torche de l'époque et nous le
retrouverons également dans Super
Villain team up en duo avec le docteur
Doom jusqu'en 1980 en fait là où la
neutralité de la mort pourrait
symboliser une faiblesse l'empêchant de
véritablement fusionner avec soit les
gentils soit les méchants et bien c'est
également une très grande force Namor et
passe-partout dès que l'histoire ou les
enjeux touchent l'océan il y a moyen de
le ramener dans l'histoire et de le
faire participer et ce peu importe les
personnages impliqués bon et par la
suite Namor suivra toujours et encore la
même trajectoire et jonglera entre
histoire du passé aventure en équipe ou
encore réécriture de son origin story je
crois personnellement que c'est l'un des
personnages qui aura eu le plus de
comics retraçant son histoire de base
mais bref je pense qu'il est désormais
temps de conclure avec une épopée qui
pour moi permet de mettre en lumière
l'essence de la mort c'est la saga New
Avengers volume 3 précédent la seconde
de Secret Wars c'est le moment où les
Illuminatis le groupe très secret de
super-héros dont Namor fait d'ailleurs
partie vont découvrir la menace
grondante que symbolise les incursions
pour plus de précisions c'est la
découverte que le multivers se contracte
et commence petit à petit à s'écrouler
et de cela va en résulter une réaction
naturelle ou les univers vont commencer
à rentrer en collision la solution au
premier abord est simple puisque quand
deux univers entre en collision cela
provoque l'anéantissement total des deux
côtés et par conséquent la totalité de
la vie qui les composait du coup il faut
détruire l'univers d'en face pour que
son monde puisse survivre sauf que bien
évidemment c'est là la grande partie du
problème même si les Illuminatis sont
composées des plus grands héros que la
terre n'est jamais connue capable de
prendre des décisions que personne ne
veut prendre on parle quand même ici de
tuer des milliards de milliards d'êtres
vivants qui n'ont rien demandé qui a les
épaules assez solide pour assumer un tel
acte dans le comics 21 de New Avengers
volume 3 nos héros font face à une
énième incursion malheureusement
personne n'a le courage d'appuyer sur le
détonateur qui fera exploser le monde
d'en face Tony Stark ne veut pas le
faire rides ne souhaite pas pour des
raisons morales Shala le Black Panther
se décourage au dernier moment bref
aucun des illuminatis n'est en capacité
mais contre toute attente Namor va
interagir le Submariner va prendre le
détonateur blâmer les Illuminatis pour
leur faiblesse ainsi que leur hypocrisie
et actionnera la bombe qui détruira le
monde prête à rentrer en collision avec
la Terre 616 c'en est trop pour l'équipe
de super-héros tout le monde se dispute
avec Namor tout le monde se sent plus
vertueux et moral que le Submariner mais
c'est l'hypocrisie la mort le roi
d'Atlantis vient de sauver son ainsi que
l'entièreté de la terre 616 il est le
seul à assumer les choix difficiles il
est le seul à avoir conscience que lui
et son équipe sont des monstres tous les
autres Illuminati se voilent la face ils
ont tous commis des atrocités ils ont
déjà détruit d'autres mondes et tu es
d'innombrables innocents et maintenant
il n'assume plus après cet événement
plus aucun des héros ne voudront gérer
les incursions les Illuminati ne veulent
plus assumer la destruction des autres
mondes et s'en iront chacun de leur côté
pour profiter de leur dernier instant
néanmoins ce n'est pas du tout le cas de
Namor qui quant à lui ne déposera pas
les armes au sol seul de son côté le
protagoniste va libérer Thanos et
l'Ordre Noir fraîchement enfermé par les
Illuminatis pour lui venir en aide
concernant les incursions c'est la
naissance de la Kabbale un groupe de
personnages destiné à détruire les
autres mondes lors des incursions
mais sera finalement mise à la porte par
Victor qui est déjà prêt à faire son
ascension dans la future Secret Wars
tout le monde a retourné sa veste face à
la mort alors qu'il est celui qui a
permis à la terre de prospérer pendant
presque un an
le fils vengeur a bien grandi désigné
comme un élu depuis son plus jeune âge
Namor a conscience de son unicité il
sait à quel point il est puissant il
sait qu'il est le seul à pouvoir
véritablement protéger l'océan et les
Atlantes ce qui le pousse à être très
arrogant et très sûr de lui en étant
considéré comme un vilain la plus grande
majorité de sa vie dans l'univers Marvel
Namor n'est pas dupe il sait de quoi il
est capable il peut être un véritable
monstre un véritable tyran ce n'est pas
un hasard s'il peut collaborer avec
d'autres vilains ou si la rejoint les
Defenders par exemple à terme la mort ne
peut pas être compatible avec les
Avengers il est une entité neutre qui a
pour seul intérêt son peuple les
Atlantes et bon en réalité Atlantis est
avant tout une excuse pour Namor nous
l'avons remarqué de par ses aventures
mais le seul mariner n'est jamais
vraiment dans son royaume il vagabonde
toujours à gauche à droite ou dans le
monde de la surface il est en couple
avec les dix Dorma mais ne la pas que de
temps en temps bref la mort agit avant
tout quand même pour lui-même il est
plutôt en réalité l'incarnation des mers
l'héritage vivant de Neptune alias
Poséidon le vrai Dieu des océans donc
d'ailleurs le trident a été conféré par
Neptune lui-même Anna mort et la
condition hybride du personnage permet à
nous humains de s'identifier à la mort
et accessoirement surtout le relier aux
histoires de la surface néanmoins je
dois vous avouer qu'il y a quand même je
trouve un goût de gâché avec Namor le
truc c'est que la Seconde Guerre
mondiale a totalement chamboulé le
destin du personnage en 1939 on est à
l'aube des comics à l'aube des
super-héros et Namor a en fait essuyé
les pots cassés de l'histoire des comics
le summariner aurait pu être l'un des
plus grandes vilains de la firme comme
c'était annoncé dès sa première
apparition mais faisant partie de la
première poignée de super-héros à être
développé en comics Namor sera
finalement adaptée à de multiples
reprises c'est malheureux à dire mais un
personnage de la mort à quelque peu eu
l'effet d'un brouillon en fait
permettant à time les publications
d'expérimenter et lors de leur
renaissance en Marvel Comics de nous
pondre l'incroyable âge d'argent et
l'aire moderne que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui Namor est l'un des plus
grands moyens de l'univers Marvel un
personnage qui a complètement marqué la
firme et qui a permis de manière globale
au comics d'évoluer et tout ce que je
vous raconte depuis le début de la vidéo
et bien c'est tout ça qui rend la mort
si unique
nous arrivons à la fin de cette vidéo
J'espère de tout cœur qu'elle vous aura
plu et bon sang Namor aura été l'un des
personnages les plus compliqués qui
m'est été donné de faire il a suivi
l'évolution complète de la firme Marvel
depuis sa création et du coup toute son
histoire est incomplète remplie d'un
cohérence ou d'éléments qui ont été
grimés avec des comics reboot au fil des
années et au final face à tous ces
noeuds bien la solution ça a été que
Namor soit rangée plutôt au second plan
comme une sorte d'accompagnateur de
récits la mort possède beaucoup
d'histoires il est quand même là depuis
1939 mais en réalité peu sont
véritablement marquantes Namor est
quelqu'un de très intéressant mais au
final c'est quand même avant tout grâce
à sa très longue longévité bref même si
la tâche fut complexe ce fut un réel
plaisir de rendre hommage à un tel
personnage j'espère que vous êtes
satisfait plein de nouvelles vidéos
pourquoi sont-ils si uniques sont en
préparation sachez-le en attendant vous
pouvez laisser un pouce bleu sur
celle-ci
ainsi qu'un commentaire et surtout
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner c'est très
important sur ce merci à tous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo c'était argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]